un bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans cette
édition d'information locale sur tv et
78 tout de suite les titres de ce set 8
journal du mardi 16 janvier est la fin
des travaux est prévue pour septembre
prochain sera pas posée ce matin la
première pierre du chantier de sa maison
des associations un équipement de 470
mètres carrés au coeur de la zac de
l'aéro stats au service des associations
locales elles sont 280 dans la ville
c'est une école de la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie paris ile de
france les cimes vient de fêter ses 25
ans basé à rambouillet l'établissement
propose 28 diplôme de bac +2 à bac +5
dans le management opérationnel et nous
en parlons avec eric de nous directeur
de les cimes
enfin c'est votre rendez vous
hebdomadaire chaque mardi dans cette
suite journal le portrait de la
rédaction rencontre ce soir avec tony
bastion à qui a lancé il ya sept ans le
cabaret du bout des prix à cerner la
ville ils l'ouvrent depuis deux ans à
une soirée avec caritatives et puis
autre invité de ce journal filet baup le
nouveau pasteur de l'église adventiste
du septième jour d'elancourt ça sera
tout à l'heure dans le journal avant de
débuter cette édition david douillet
dans le viseur de la justice l'ancien
parlementaire et l'ère des yvelines est
pointé du doigt par la haute autorité
pour la transparence de la vie publique
c'est à propos de la déclaration de
patrimoine de fin de mandat il est
reproché à l'ex député de la 12e
circonscription d'avoir sous-évalué son
patrimoine
dans un communiqué la haute autorité
évoque des doutes sérieux quant à
l'exhaustivité l'exactitude et la
sincérité de la déclaration
le dossier a été transmis au procureur
de la république de paris
c'est un geste symbolique qui marque le
début des travaux la première pierre de
la future maison et des associations de
trappes vient d'être posée ce nouvel
établissement permettra notamment de
mieux accompagner les structures
associatives à partir de la fin de
l'année un reportage de nicolas kirilow
liszt pour l'instant ce n'est qu'un
terrain vague avec seulement quelques
parpaings poser dans quelques mois c'est
ici à trappes que ce bâtiment flambant
neuf sera inauguré
et un bâtiment dédié entièrement au 281
associations de la ville et qui doit
leur profiter de points d'appui pour
l'ensemble de leurs projets les
associations peuvent se retrouver
préparer leur dossier préparé leurs
différentes actions
à voir sur place un ou deux partenaires
municipal jouant ici pas si vous voulez
qui est capable de donner des réponses
d'ordre juridique dans financier suivre
l'organisation situé en plein coeur du
quartier de l'aérostat qui prévoit à
terme la construction de 800 logements
ce nouvel équipement public répond aux
besoins du tissu associatif local vie
culturelle sportive ou solidaire il doit
permettre également de pérenniser les
projets innovants et à des niveaux qui
vont s'opérer au niveau de la mda à la
fois stabiliser aider les associations
existantes et à la fois faire en sorte
que d'autres jeunes puisse émerger
parce que dans le monde à cet effet
également c'est du bénévolat il arrive à
un moment où les gens sont essoufflés il
va falloir remplacer il faut que ça
continue il faut que la société puisse
continuer à servir comme bien des tissus
social de la ville de trappes la
livraison du bâtiment est prévue pour
septembre 2018 coût de l'opération un
peu moins de 2 millions d'euros
autre pose de la première pierre d'un
projet celui ci fera dix neuf mille
mètres carrés sur six niveaux
le centre hospitalier
poissy-saint-germain-en-laye aura une
nouvelle extension lancement officiel
des travaux hier en présence de la
ministre des solidarités de la santé
agnès buzyn le dossier suscite depuis
plusieurs années des tensions entre
politiques et professionnels
hospitaliers
les détails avec ce sujet de les arrêts
g patrick jacques de dixmude une
première pierre en légaux posés devant
les travaux du nouveau bâtiment du
centre hospitalier de poissy saint
germain en laye la ministre des
solidarités et de la santé agnès buzyn
était présente lors de cet événement
symbolique
autour d'elle de nombreuses
personnalités politiques gérard larcher
valérie pécresse pierre bédier ou encore
karl olive le projet de l'extension du
site finalise d'une certaine manière le
long processus de fusion engagée en 1997
entre les deux sites hospitaliers
aujourd'hui on est sur des conditions
d'accueil qui sont un petit peu
difficile par rapport aux standards
habituels et donc là le nouveau bâtiment
va permettre justement d'atteindre ses
standards objectif de ce projet
immobilier moderniser les modes de prise
en charge développer les coopérations
médical et assurer la mise aux normes de
certaines activités sanitaires
les plans prévoient un bâtiment de 19
mille mètres carrés sur six étages en
centre financé pour moitié par le
ministère et l'agencé régionale de santé
ars et l'autre moitié par
l'établissement
c'est un contrat gagnant gagnant avec la
rs pour pouvoir aujourd'hui avoir un
projet qui est bien d un périmètre de 70
millions d'euros à la fois sur poissy
mais aussi sur saint germain en laye
avec une restructuration autour de
l'accueil de jour et des
hospitalisations qui soit plus content
pour cette première symbolique une
cinquantaine de manifestants étaient
réunis pour contester le projet si vous
n'avez pas de praticiens si vous n'êtes
pas personnel vous aurez toujours autant
de que halle aux urgences de poissy
puisqu'il arrive parfois d'avoir des
records d'attenté à tubize heures avant
d'être soigné la dernière pierre de ce
nouveau bâtiment du centre hospitalier
poissy-saint-germain-en-laye doit être
posée en avril 2020 en ce début 2018 il
n'y a pas que les villes qui présentent
leurs voeux le secours populaire des
yvelines aussi souhaité une bonne année
à ses bénévoles cérémonie conviviale
autour d'une galette des rois le
week-end dernier à trappes est
l'occasion de revenir sur 2010 est
marquée par les 50 ans de la fédération
départementale
elle note une hausse de 5 à 10% de ses
bénéficiaires il serait un peu plus de
7000 sur le territoire et le secrétaire
général entend promouvoir la solidarité
dans un
contexte de déchirures sociales écoutez
le au micro de nicolas d'andrus
malheureusement on a toujours de plus en
plus de monde qui vient nous voir et ce
qui m'inquiète un peu ce qui inquiète un
peu les bénévoles c'est que on a des
publics comme les seniors qui ont
tendance à s'accroître dans les
permanences d'accueil
donc ça veut dire que si les seniors
commence à venir maintenant les
générations qui vont venir après
vraiment être dans la difficulté et puis
on a aussi le problème des migrants et
des gens qui sont de plus en plus dans
les hôtels et dans des situations très
précaires et où franchement on ne voit
pas trop on voit pas trop l'horizon
ce sens b s'embellir on sait pas trop
comment comment ça va se passer
et pour cette année 2010 8 le secours
populaire entend renforcer notamment le
secteur vacances
il pourra compter sur un budget de 700
mille euros vous pouvez adresser un don
à la fédération départementale via le
site internet qui s'affiche à maurepas
présentait également ses voeux en fin de
semaine dernière au gymnase de la malle
ne donne au cours de la cérémonie la
commune a notamment reçu une deuxième
fleur pour son label ville fleurie aide
les annonces à retenir de la part du
maire à grégory gars restiez sur la
politique menée en 2018 beaucoup de
travaux par exemple en centre ville sur
l'avenue du forez et mais aussi des
projets intercommunaux qui vont voir le
jour avec coignières et elancourt propos
collectées par mélanie poker
à terme c'est le regroupement de nos
polices municipales qui va compter plus
de 40 agents donc on démarre déjà avec
la ville de coignières dans un premier
temps pour arriver à une quinzaine
d'agents et ensuite on fusionnera avec
les services de police de la ville
d'elancourt pour créer évidemment une
police intercommunale très importante
dans les yvelines
avec plus de 40 agents c'est mieux
d'unir nos forces pour justement lutter
contre l'insécurité et répondre aux
besoins de nos habitants et c'est vrai
que nous avons des frontières qui sont
très poreuse et la délinquance ou les
problèmes du quotidien ajustements n'ont
pas de frontières et le travail sur
d'autres projets intercommunaux va se
poursuivre notamment autour d'une
piscine intercommunale qui les travaux
dont les travaux devraient débuter en
2019 elle a fêté un quart de siècle les
cimes l'école supérieure des systèmes de
management à 25 ans l'établissement basé
à rambouillet a célébré cet anniversaire
en grande pompe le 14 décembre dernier à
la chambre de commerce et d'industrie de
paris ile de france c'était à c'était à
paris a donc avec mon plateau pour en
parler eric de new bond soir consomment
si vous êtes le directeur de
les simon va présenter avec vous bien
sûr cette école c'est différent diplômés
et filières déjà sur cette soirée de 25
ans il était important de de fêter ça
avec les élèves les anciens et aussi les
partenaires c'était important
mais oui 25 ans c'est un anniversaire je
suis bien placé pour le dire qu'ils ne
se renouvellent pas donc il faut il faut
vraiment le vivre et on avait beaucoup
de choses à célébrer à l'occasion de ses
25 ans la soirée pour parler d'elle
s'est bien déroulé on avait à peu près
200 personnes qui étaient là on avait le
président du sénat monsieur larcher qui
chez qui n'a pas pu venir mais qui a été
représentée par monsieur marc robert le
maire de rambouillet et qui est venu
témoigner je j'expliquerai pourquoi
parce que monsieur larcher était
sénateur maire a au moment de
l'ouverture de cette école en 1992 ela
nous a tout particulièrement
t'accompagner aux lions de ses 25 ans la
soirée de 25 ans a été aussi l'occasion
de faire des tables rondes à une table
ronde notamment où a été présenté les
joutes prud'homale qui est y sont une
action menée par par l'établissement
c'est un mode d'accompagnement
pédagogique spécifique puis savez nous
sommes une école qui forme 100% par
apprentissage et nous formons des
managers puisque nous formons de bac +2
à bac +5 et aujourd'hui les entreprises
sont évidemment demandeuses de plus en
plus notamment
non seulement je voulais dire
d'étudiants formés à bac + 5 mai
d'étudiants très opérationnelle qui soit
adaptable dès le premier jour qu'ils
arrivent et nous avons effectivement une
pédagogie qui est adapté les joutes
prud'homale c'est effectivement sur un
cas réel en partenariat avec le tribunal
des prud'hommes de rambouillet est
accompagné par des le président du
tribunal par un certain nombre de
conseillers prud'homaux nous faisons
intervenir deux deux formations
différentes
des gens qui se forme en ressources
humaines des gens qui se font en
contrôle de gestion et les deux
finalement joue une espèce de joutes
prud'homale sur un cas réel et c'est
absolument extraordinaire parce qu'on
s'aperçoit qu'il joue véritablement le
jeu et et qu'ils rentrent dans un jeu de
rôle
comme en situation réelle et c'est très
intéressant parce que du coup il
s'adapte le but de cet exercice
pédagogique c'est de pouvoir s'adapter à
l'évolution aussi non seulement des
contraintes de notre marché et des
attentes de nos entreprises et vous
savez très bien que la réglementation
sociale et prud'homales et voler
beaucoup donc c'est aussi une formation
à l'adaptabilité 25 ans pour une école
ça signifie quoi c'est du travail
accompli qui est qui et where
récompenser une bonne implantation sur
le territoire qu'est ce que ça signifie
25 ans alors déjà un choix très
pertinent puisque effectivement
s'installer à rambouillet n'était pas
forcément à l'origine une idée qui
pouvait séduire à long terme et pour
autant nous sommes passés de 36 jeunes
sortis diplômés en 94 à 1200 cette année
et avec une croissance qui est assez
assez phénoménal puisque sur un marché
national de l'apprentissage qui est
stable à 400 milles à peu près apprentis
depuis dix ans nous avons quasiment
multiplié nos effectifs par trois sur ce
même créneau uniquement pour la raison
que je précisais précédemment c'est que
effectivement de plus en plus en
formation de haut niveau l'apprentissage
est une valeur ajoutée complémentaire
donc on a fêté ça on a fêté le 10.000e
apprentis oui donc il ya diplômés et en
a fêté une croissance aussi géographique
puisque j'allais vous lancez une antenne
à montigny-le-bretonneux et depuis la
rentrée 2010 est un jeune vie des villes
une antenne petite couronne paris exact
que nous avons ouverte effectivement à
la rentrée dernière et qui nous permet
d'attraper une zone de chalandise
nous avions déjà depuis un certain
nombre d'années des demandes de jeunes
et d'entreprises sur cette zone
trop éloigné de rentrer de vraiment de
rambouillet pour pouvoir la couvrir
sereinement et donc aujourd'hui nous
avons ouvert cette antenne donc notre
extension se précisent aussi et nous
devrions arriver à 1600 1700 jeunes de
diplômés à l'horizon 2020 les succès une
école de la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie par ile de france ça
signifie quoi certes ya un lien plus
direct avec les entreprises
alors déjà les sims et l'école
supérieure des systèmes de management
donc ça c'est déjà quelque chose qui
rassure c'est un management très
opérationnel je rappelle que nous
formons à 100% en apprentissage
et son appartenance à la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie paris ile de
france est une très forte caution pour
les parents pour les jeunes eux-mêmes
pour les entreprises et c'est la
démonstration d'un savoir-faire
consulaires aussi en matière de
formation notamment par apprentissage
qui est effectivement rassurons 28
diplômes sont proposés au sein de
lessines du bac +2 à bac +5
quelles filières ça concerne et
finalement concrètement ça sert à faire
quoi après ces filières alors écoutez
nous formons effectivement le bac +2 à
bac +5 nous avons plusieurs types de
formation des formations éducation
nationale des formations avec des titres
consulaires qui nous appartiennent ou
qui sont en tout cas du réseau roseaux
consulaires et nous avons un très fort
partenariat avec l'université de
versailles saint-quentin-en-yvelines
puisque nous avons 12 masters avec eux
et nous avons au niveau bac + 5 ou 6 à 1
dscg alors ça ça signifie effectivement
une offre très large une formation sur
trois filières force le management
opérationnel
le les ressources humaines et tout ce
qui est métier finance gestion
comptabilité
pour faire simple les cimes est capable
de fournir aujourd'hui 100 % des
demandes de 100 % des entreprises
puisqu'il n'est une entreprise qui n'est
pas besoin ni de rh management de
finances gestion comptabilité et les
professeurs les intervenants les signes
qui sont ils alors les intervenants sont
pour 95% des intervenants professionnels
en entreprise très bien toutes ces
filières dont vous avez parlé on les
retrouve sur les sur l'ensemble des
décide de lessines où chaque chaque site
propose finalement des filières
différentes
en fait nous avons réparti nos
formations sur les sites le site
nouvellement ouvert un jeune billy et
incite surtout spécialisé ressources
humaines à rambouillet bien sûr nous
formons sur les 3es à montigny nous
avons deux bts alors qu'ils sont à
cheval sur deux deux filières oui la
filière ressources humaines la filière
management deux dernières questions
passées par les îles mais ce que ça
ouvre des portes finalement le taux
d'insertion professionnelle après et il
est il au écouter aujourd'hui nous avons
93 % d'insertion professionnelle à 7
mois et nous avons un taux de réussite
aux examens de
non vous avez nous avons 93 % de
réussite aux examens 83% pardonnez-moi
de taux d'intérêt bien après sept mois
et nous avons surtout plus de 1200
entreprises partenaires qui nous fait
qu'on qui nous font confiance
durablement pour ses 25 ans qu'est ce
qu'on peut souhaiter à laisser une
dernière question bien la poursuite d'un
partenariat la poursuite un partenariat
au niveau pédagogique au niveau
évidemment commerciales avec nos
entreprises partenaires qui sont nous
nos principaux alliés
on a une fidélisation qui est assez
assez remarquable le développement d'une
marque rh sans doute au sein de notre
école qui est en train de vraiment de se
positionner avec oui une offre à un peu
spécifique surtout développé avec des
titres et qui correspond véritablement à
l'évolution vraiment constante des
métiers ressources humaines et notre
pédagogie est particulièrement adapté à
sa merci eric de nous d'avoir une
fonderie c'était un plaisir merci de
m'avoir invité directeur de l'estimé
pour plus d'informations sur cette école
vous pouvez bien sûr vous rendre sur le
site internet qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran
le château de versailles lance sa
troisième job academy c'était et hier
comme vous le voyez à sur ces images de
mélanie poké une promotion de 13
demandeurs d'emploi baptisé jules
hardouin mansart va être accompagné par
13 parrains et marraines tous agents du
château cette action est initié par face
yvelines club d'entreprises ayant pour
mission de fédérer d'accompagner les
acteurs économiques du département dans
leur engagement sociétal est jeune
académie est une action qu'on développe
maintenant depuis cinq ans sur le
territoire et qui permet à des
professionnels en place
d'accompagner des personnes en recherche
d'emploi donc il se rend compte
individuellement tous les quinze jours
et ils ont en plus des ateliers
collectifs qui sont animés par des
professionnels du château de versailles
short un an poursuit ce journal avec un
nouvel invité kim a rejoint en plateau
c'est philippe bock bonsoir bonsoir musa
vitalité merci à vous d'avoir accepté
notre invitation depuis fin 2010 est
vous êtes le pasteur le nouveau pasteur
de l'église adventiste du septième jour
d'elancourt l église adventiste est une
église chrétienne qui fait partie de la
fédération protestante de france on va
parler de tout ça dans un instant
première question à quoi ressemble et
les premières semaines d'un pasteur
quand il arrive dans une dans une
nouvelle communauté
c'est d'abord une prise de contact oui
faire connaissance avec ses nouveaux
membres d'églises développer ainsi une
relation humaine fraternelle et amicale
et puis à partir de là essayer de vaquer
aux occupations pastorale la visite chez
l'habitant et différentes autres
activités inhérentes à cette fonction
alors vous n'êtes pas sûr je crois sur
trois églises 700 oui je suis pasteur à
fontainebleau est également amorçant
donc j'ai un territoire assez assez
répandue est assez large sur la
communauté adventiste à elancourt
combien de fidèles ça représente hors de
fidèles nous sommes une cinquantaine
mais j'entends les membres inscrits aux
registres de l'église c'est à dire
baptisé selon le rite du baptême par
immersion d'accord qui ne s'adresse
qu'aux adultes
du moins aux personnes qui ont
suffisamment de maturité pour comprendre
ce qu'ils font et je ne compte pas dans
ce nombre les jeunes et les
sympathisants ce qui fait qu'en
population le samedi matin puisque nous
nous réunissons le samedi matin nous
sommes entre 90 et 100 et l'église
adventiste du septième jour en france
la plante est organisé en deux
fédérations l'église la fédération
france nord la fédération franc sud en
fédération france nord dans laquelle se
situe l'église d'elancourt nous sommes
un petit peu plus de dix mille membres
inscrits sur les registres de toutes ces
églises et celle d'el en cours et celle
de la france et celle du à l'échelle du
monde c'est l'église est implantée aussi
dans plusieurs plaies dans plusieurs
pays où les pays
je dirais pratiquement tous je n'ai pas
le chiffre exact moyenne et en
population nous pourrions dire que c'est
aujourd'hui un entre 30 et 40 millions
d'ha dentiste sur la planète et de
membres inscrits 14 15 peut-être un
aujourd'hui alors quelques éléments de
présentation pour les personnes qui ne
connaissent pas l église adventiste du
septième jour plusieurs notions déjà à
définir qui est qu'est ce qu'on entend
par adventiste c'est ça faire étant ce à
quoi le moins de ventes east signifie en
anglais ce qu'ils attendent le retour du
christ ceux qui sont portés par cette
espérance du retour du christ faut
savoir que lorsque le christ est parti
les anges qui étaient là disent qu'il
reviendra de la même manière donc voilà
la tante particulière des adventistes du
septième jour indiqué dans les journaux
et septième jour justement parce que
nous avons pour habitude de nous réunir
non pas le dimanche qu'on ne font
l'ensemble des chrétiens et le samedi
car nous croyons c'était là la pratique
du christ et qu'il est dès lors bond de
la conserver alors je lui ai dit tout à
l'heure l'église fait partie de la
fédération protestante de licences
telles différences en matière de domme
je sais qu'on peut pas rentrer dans les
détails mais par rapport à d'autres
courants du protest du protestantisme
je parlerai des spécificités adventiste
la première je viens de l'indiquer
attendent le retour du christ et leur
espérance notre espérance la deuxième je
les ai indiqué aussi nous nous
réunissons le samedi12 observons le
sabbat nous
nous avons d'autres spécificités
théologie comme par exemple la théologie
du sanctuaire céleste sinon nous nous
retrouvons avec l'ensemble du
protestantisme classique je dirais alors
pourrait fermer cet aveu quelques
questions sur l'actualité
l'église adventiste a fêté l'an passé
c'est sans temps de présence en france
si on revient sur l'histoire très
rapidement de l'église
elle est née en fait dans la deuxième
moitié du 19e siècle aux états unis ce
soir elle est née effectivement dans ce
qu'on appelait à l'époque la nouvelle
angleterre la deuxième moitié du 19e
siècle où talent est en fait le fruit
d'un mouvement adventiste à dire qu'il y
annoncer le retour du christ en ce temps
là dans tous les milieux protestants 10
et l'angélique aujourd'hui et à partir
de cette sensibilisation à ce cette fois
cette pensée en 1863 officiellement née
la première église adventiste du
septième jour aux états unis et
l'arrivée en france comment c'était le
début du 20e siècle début du 20e siècle
je n'ai pas la date exacte de la
première église adventiste française
moussa doit tourner aux alentours de
entre 1910-1920 autres anniversaires
importants est là ça concernait toute la
communauté protestante la commémoration
des 500 ans de la réforme protestante
le 21 octobre 15 117 je rappelle en
martin luther afficher ses 95 thèses sur
les portes de la chapelle du château de
vite un bear en saxe il jetait alors les
bases du protestantisme walhalla c'était
un anniversaire très très important pour
toute la communauté
oui puisque du fait de son appartenance
au protestantisme l'attentisme est
particulièrement attaché à la
justification par la foi dont lutter est
le premier promoteur et qui justifie en
grande partie sa réforme et dernière
question très rapide en 2018 quels sont
les temps forts pour l'église adventiste
du septième jour laquelle tellancourt
delà des langues
oui mais l'envol pour nous relocalisons
tout ça nous organisons le
27 de ce mois le dernier samedi du mois
de janvier une énigme biblique c'est un
jeu qui est organisé par nos jeunes
notamment
il s'agit en essayant de porter le
regard dans la bible de résoudre une
énigme
je veux souligner que c'est une activité
ouverte à tous donc si certains
voulaient nous rejoindre à cette
occasion ils sont les bienvenus merci
d'avoir été avec nous filer pop c'est
moi qui vous remercie je rappelle que
vous êtes le pasteur de l'église
adventiste du septième jour d'elancourt
et vous pouvez avoir plus d'informations
sur l'église adventiste sur le site
internet qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
comme chaque mardi le portrait de la
rédaction consacrer une personnalité du
département ce soir nous vous emmenons
dans un univers glamour de paillettes et
surtout patient à cerner la ville il ya
sept ans tony à bastian a lancé un
cabaret à d'inspiration lido moulin
rouge ou encore crazy horse et depuis
deux ans il ouvre ce cabaret à la soirée
inattendue en faveur de l'association on
attend le combat d'un ange
rencontre avec mélanie poker
[Musique]
derrière le costume un artiste yvelinois
tony bastions pendant trois ans il a été
le baryton de la franchise française des
voca people
les chanteurs a cappella une audition je
suis pas du tout en habitué des
auditions au contraire mais j'ai vu ce
spectacle un jour à bobino et quand je
les ai vus j'ai dit faut absolument que
je romps dans cette troupe et l'audition
est arrivé en france et je les passais
et j'ai passé toutes les étapes et je
suis rentré ça a été magique
[Musique]
mais son premier amour artistique c'est
la trompette tony bastian comment son
parcours culturel que musicien qui prend
sa source dans son enfance
mon papa était trompettiste j'ai vu donc
copier mon héros mon père donc voilà
j'ai voulu faire de la trompette comme
lui et puis j'ai fait des études aux
conservatoires de versailles et le chant
était lié avec la trompette donc je me
suis aperçu que la trompette on était un
petit peu derrière et moi j'avais envie
d'être un petit peu plus de vent sur
scène donc j'ai pris le champ voilà un
devant sur scène qui le pousse à un
projet fou en janvier 2011 il lance un
cabaret à cerner la ville sur le modèle
des références parisienne le cabaret du
bout des prêts un projet réalisé avec
son entourage notamment son épouse
rencontrée sur les bancs du lycée à tony
le chant la présentation et la partie
administrative
amandine elle dansait s'occupe des
costumes un passionné comme il dit voilà
s'il n'y a pas de spectacle il y manque
un truc il se sent pas bien c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui en complément
enfin qui fait partie de sa vie c'est ça
fait partie de ces enfants aussi si le
cabaret et les spectacles en général un
monde de glamour et de paillettes qu'ils
ouvrent depuis deux ans un petit garçon
[Applaudissements]
chance et aussi parce que les artistes y
en a de plus en plus donc j'espère que
vous n'avez rien vu jusqu'à 10 heures la
soirée inattendue vient en aide à nathan
10 ans atteint d'une maladie
neurologique orpheline un artiste
talentueux avec un énorme coeur est très
généreux et ben voilà il a tout fait
donc il propose sa voix et propose son
cabaret ses danseuses aussi son réseau
d'artistes un nouveau projet lancé avec
huit chanteurs tony bastion fonde les
nouveaux compagnons un album sort au
printemps
voilà c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal
reportages et replay retrouver sur notre
application mobile tv et 78 ainsi que
sur notre site internet très bonne
soirée à tous
[Musique]